I wanted to ask you about the teacher
and I want Bobby to get this picture up
there's a teacher in Canada who's a
trans teacher the giantess yes it's like
everybody's the same [ __ ] stories
everybody it's the same giant hits yes I
mean what is she doing in that class for
well no I mean
it's the same thing I think last week it
was the LA school system saying that
food is and your bid on it was
hysterically funny thank you but the
thing and I listened to your bit I just
laughed and laughed about let's tell
kids that all the foods are the same why
not the difference between the food sure
it was the best take on it oh thank you
but that thing which is just somebody
yeah who works at La unified po went
like this right and then plowing yes and
so then there was I listened to some
other podcasts that I actually like but
it was a very serious discussion do we
need this yeah and every it goes around
the bases and everybody takes a turn
well so now it's like who's got to take
yeah that's the thing it I could ignore
this story if they weren't that big
they're so massively big that it this
person wants you to discuss it yeah but
she doesn't need the whole planet Earth
to discuss it you don't get tits that
big if you don't think they want
everybody on Earth you want them to be
able to see the scene from space she
wants there's no way when getting these
tits like cheated but people have a
right to be [ __ ] stupid yes people
have this is the problem right now
there's no local stupidity yes
localized stupidity yeah like there was
the the woman in somewhere also Canada
it all leaks out it's Global if you do
something stupid you are gonna [ __ ]
die from shame right because the entire
is gonna be Joy read right and
eventually Putin right will say that
they shouldn't let that woman
it will get there that's how he's
motivating he's the Army no one gets to
just be like you know this it's just the
same as like [ __ ] there's no coffee
shop down the street which is Starbucks
it doesn't matter where you are right so
it's not like you know what I like about
you know or or whatever [ __ ] Eugene
Oregon is that coffee place I used to go
no it's right you know what I like about
Eugene Oregon the same thing as the
airport in Cincinnati yeah it's just the
Starbucks yeah so no one gets to have a
little local culture with the you know
there's a weird person down there you
know yeah like that woman who was like
the NAACP chapter head who is white
white yeah Rachel dolezal yeah I'll see
you know her name she should have she
should have been able yeah I'm not
chastising you for noise you're the only
you're the only end user that's
worthwhile for any of this right right
but that woman should have been able to
be weird
I said let Alec bolden's wife pretend to
be Spanish I said let her pretend to be
black I think no sure yeah her name's
hilarious she's she's pretending to be a
rich Spanish lady she's not LARPing as a
maid she's not on all fours she's not
cleaning floors she's she's pretending
to be a rich better do you know the
difference between a rich Brazilian
woman and a rich Jewish woman not that
much difference so I was like just let
her put on an accent she just wants to
have an affectation yeah she wants to
see you know she goes to these parties
these rich white [ __ ] every day she
wants to be a little different she wants
to stand out and her husband's Alec
[ __ ] Baldwin he just dominates all
the news so like just for her to be like
okay Justice for something yes for
somebody to go and where are you oh
where are you from and she goes uh you
know it's just something fun for her
sure yeah but you know so she wants to
be International that's right she
married a man who's an International
Celebrity and yeah you know gun the guy
so I mean and I so I've always been I'm
for letting everyone pretend to be
everything yes but you then you have
folks like uh the kids in a in in
Wisconsin
I think it was yeah who were taking a
class picture
and somebody said do a Nazi salute it's
a joke and they're just they're kids on
the planet Earth
in the middle of Wisconsin with a lot of
empty space around them yes and and they
they're living in a town that doesn't
benefit from a global Community right
just in a little place during a little
couch and they want to make a dumb they
want to make a dumb joke yes and they do
the Nazis so go ahead and like freeze
frame this
and meme I knew it he's a Nazi go ahead
right I can take it you can take it but
those young but those kids are just what
you know yeah I mean God the [ __ ] you
said when you're in junior high school
yeah and then somebody would throw up
and there it is throw up a secret oh now
we're doing it yeah now we're [ __ ]
let's give that another all they they're
all all everyone in that picture was
like thank God that died down and now
we're bringing it back it's a nightmares
of never-ending nightmare
it's a NE I mean comedy is a terrible
part of this cycle well it's a terrible
part but these kids and then it's like
and then [ __ ] people from [ __ ]
assignment reason thought yeah going you
know or whoever the [ __ ] yeah they're
like it's like Auschwitz all over again
yeah it's just like the yeah this is
yeah I mean come on let them do a dumb
thing over there yes yeah well it's what
you you really hit on it brilliantly
with that term localized stupidity yeah
that doesn't exist and the idea that
people need to be stupid in their local
town and they need to have somebody go
hey you're an idiot and it doesn't need
to be national news and it doesn't need
to be in cultural moment or
international news no it just needs to
be something that's kind of quickly
forgotten right but what's not going to
stop any of that yeah is that there's
profit in it that's right do you ever
walk in your house and there's junk mail
on the floor like 10 cents
so now that's sent to a business manager
but yeah but it exists of course I still
get junk mail right with a little window
in the envelope with plastic in it yeah
then there's they put some in the window
that makes you that looks like a dollar
or something right
the idea I mean junk mail physical junk
mail work to take to to get in on the on
the scam yeah to be suckered yeah you
have to open it and fill it in and and
send it in and send it they might make
10 cents a month right
but it's worth it it's worth it it's
worth it it's a little more than they're
spending and so as long as that's and
then the internet there's no physical
you just go like damn [ __ ] you know
and the the trick with the media is just
put a question mark yeah just like this
uh Scandal uh you know uh uh Robin
Williams was actually murdered by Sean
Penn right question what this gets you
out of the liability yeah I don't know
maybe yeah somewhere in the somewhere in
the story you bury you do absolutely not
it didn't happen but people go huh as
long as that'll make 10 cents right
they'll do it there's always a profit
motive that you know yeah like going
back to Iran for a moment the last time
I ran was the big thing for us was in
1980 when the there's the hostages right
yeah uh the Shah of Iran nobody
remembers this these you know you all
think that you know Paul uh Simon was in
The Beatles so you're not gonna know
what I'm talking about right but there
was uh the shave Iran was a puppet
dictator that we
a direct employee of the United States
that's right
and he was ejected by the Ayatollah and
by the Iranians who because he was in he
put incredible suffering on the Iranian
people just American uh paid for
suffering right I don't remember what
our why we made money doing this yeah
maybe they because they had oil I don't
know
but anyway when he so then there was
this thing with the Ayatollah and then
everyone was they were ex they took
hostages so we were expelling Iranians
out of the country we were throwing
submaranians out of the country and my
mom and my dad we lived in Massachusetts
then and my mom was at MIT learning
computers and she knew this guy who in
Cambridge he knew a bunch of that there
was he just was this guy he reminded me
of you a little bit that he's just a guy
who gets he's got his capitalism he's
right there you know what I mean right
so he figured out that there's Iranian
families all over Cambridge that are
needing to leave this week right
and they all bought their kids trans
amps they all bought their kids that
1978 black Trans Am with a gold eagle
that was Burt reynolds's car right in
Smokey and the bandits yeah and so he
knew that there was all these so he went
around to the houses of people like
frantically packing and said how much
for your Trans Am and he bought like 50
Trans Ams so we're brand new for nothing
put them all on a lot he bought a he
bought a a used car lot for like a week
and just moved them made a fortune yeah
so as long as people are making money on
that you're just not going to stop it
yeah it wasn't a great analogy but
that's what that's why the woman with
the big tits yeah because it's just
paying off like a slot machine and she's
just being drilled into it I mean either
that or maybe she's like maybe she's
flourishing maybe it feels good I don't
know but I but I have a feeling it's
really not fun for her and for the kids
in her class and for the teachers and
the school and all the local people see
this is good
I never think about it like that yeah so
that's what I mean if you're gonna if
you go after you know [ __ ] uh share
for her the new lip or whatever the [ __ ]
it's a different thing I agree but
there's there's I'm not even saying you
shouldn't do it no no no because I enjoy
listening no I understand but there's a
certain thing now there is a new social
contract whether people like it or not
and I think there's a lot of things to
not like about it we've Illustrated a
thousand of them but there is a new
social contract where if you get tits
that are bigger than anything that
anyone has ever seen and you teach in a
school where you're in a shop class you
teach shop you solder things together
these tits you know my shop teacher's
name is Mr swanovsky he was a creepy old
guy and this is what every shop teacher
should be he was a creepy old dude who
never smiled and would just make a face
when we were doing something because we
were never doing the right thing and he
just cared about soldering irons and
hitting them up and just making sure
that the little dumb rods that you know
and we put together these little things
that were meant nothing and none of
these skills mean anything because you
hire someone anyway it's one of it's the
least valuable position in a school and
you know that because everything you do
is fake nobody in shop class goes you
know what I want to be an architect it
never happens what happens is like you
just make little [ __ ] things all day
and and then these kids just and you
just try kids the only thing in Shoppers
don't hurt yourself it's the only thing
in child class just don't kill yourself
don't hurt yourself please don't
embarrass me don't go to the nurse we
don't want any accidents in fact the
first three days of chop are him telling
you about all the horrible things that
have happened to other kids that didn't
listen that talk during the safety
precaution this guy burns his hand this
guy can't use his pinky everything's
[ __ ] and it's such a horrible job it's
a bad job it's not even like biology
right where at least you can go like
they need to know this it's nothing and
then this woman goes and says I'm gonna
get the biggest tip that anyone has ever
seen not big tits I'm talking about the
cartoonist because it's to the point
where it literally I have to now stand
back a foot and a half from the saw yeah
when I'm teaching the kids because these
kids now are in between the kids and
these shop [ __ ] things and it's so
cartoonish that she Waddles around this
room with the big big tits and then you
see and we should be allowed to laugh at
her because she's done a ridiculous
thing
she's done a ridiculous thing but I get
I get why a trans person would like shop
class because it's like we're building
things right everything can be built
yeah sure kids everything can be built
nothing's everything can be soldered
yeah and I get it I totally get it if I
was trans I would a class like that to
me I'd go this is good I'd want to teach
biology right I want to teach look what
we can build right but it's just when
you do it with such cartoonishly big
tits then the world should have at the
world should because you want it
you want it if so here's what here's
what okay here's what just happened that
I really enjoy yeah I'd like to just
observe sure
so the whole time that I was making the
point about localized stupidity yeah and
why do it the whole time and I remember
that remember the last few minutes this
yeah
it's like we were sitting in this car
that you're sitting there you're just
ready to go yeah and the engine is going
and I'm going like we don't need to do
this to people yeah it's too much it's
over over proportioned and you're going
uh-huh are you done okay and then you
went you just went this and then you
just did well a big yeah bit about this
lady because she it it needs to happen
yeah in fact what I view comedy as is
this weird like
you know these dumb [ __ ] who walk
around houses in L.A with sage burning
yeah and they go I'm like getting rid of
the energy so the house will sell yeah
or whatever right oh yeah this is what
comedy is to me in in a weird way you we
need to kind of like there needs to be a
moment where everybody laughs at these
big tits yes and then we can all look I
can I could get with that on some level
without the tits It's academic
this woman did not get those tits to be
ignored she did not get those
no but she's got okay put it away
she has a body dysmorphia yeah but
she didn't want to be on the Tim Dylan
show oh I don't
she didn't want to be on the Tim Dylan I
don't know about that man those did
there you can't you get those to be
ignored
not but yeah by the you it's not the
point the point is you got something
tells you that that's what you need I
don't know but it's a very internal
thing
external thing yeah well it manifests
yeah it's a very external thing too I
mean I get what you mean and I'm not I'm
not saying she shouldn't be no listen
here's the problem is that once things
float up right to the comedy yeah I get
it and I have again my issue is not with
you no of course it really isn't well of
course
of course but by yourself
no of course of course no it couldn't be
me
um
I mean what I believe about comedy is
that there is no moral arrow in comedy
there's no moral up or down there's no
moral gravity and comedy that's what we
do and yes I do think that on some level
it's like
you're saging out all those serious [ __ ]
that got said about her yes and the
people I'm sure got really angry on both
sides well both sides the left and the
right tits any of the sides yeah and
either tit either one